[Musique]
ce que le conseil de l'europe a fait
c'est à dire la promotion du hidjab et
en voilant des femmes et en trouvant que
c'était bien que c'était leur liberté en
présentant cette façon extrêmement
positive alors effectivement le ministre
s'est indigné mais il n'a pas répondu à
ma question justement ou lui demander
s'il allait faire une enquête pour
savoir d'où venait cet entrisme et le
ministre n'a pas répondu à ma question
sur quelles mesures allez vous prendre
quelle leçon en tirer et quelles
sanctions pour de vous prendre on est
quand même là aux peurs de nos libertés
fondamentales et renoncer sur ces
questions et bien pour moi c'est une
trahison une trahison à nos valeurs et
je ne souhaite pas que le conseil de
l'europe soit le cheval de troie de
l'islam politique est aujourd'hui c'est
le cas donc mes questions étaient
précises
y at il une enquête qui a permis ce
genre de communication veillé par les
impôts des européens comment comment la
france va réagir
[Musique]
on pense que ce championnat est placé
sous l'égide
de l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes donc de qui se moque t'on
aujourd'hui aussi bien en france pour
les français qu en europe pour les
européens et je trouve dangereux
scandaleux aussi qu'on laisse les choses
dérivés comme ça sur le plan politique
parce que moi je suis heureuse d'être
française et d'être française en europe
l'europe c'est aussi notre civilisation
et l'abandonné à la lâcheté politique
sain service pendants à personne
[Musique]